hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the chenai grand Masters
tournament it is pentala Hari Krishna
versus gkes and gkes needs only a draw
to qualify for the candidates tournament
or to almost qualify for the candidates
tournament if he gets a draw or wins
this game with the black pieces he will
overtake Anish giri in the fiday circuit
and have excellent chances of qualifying
for the fiday candidates tournament uh
those chances being that we still have
the world rapid and Blitz Championship
that will be from 26th to 30th of
December and it is possible that someone
has a brilliant event wins the event and
overtakes um gkes in that tournament but
that is still to be seen it's a really
erratic tournament and anyone can beat
anyone so it's very difficult to
actually count on that so let's see what
happened in this one pentala with the
white pieces opens with uh Pawn to D4 we
have Pawn to D5 and now Pawn to C4 uh D
captures and C4 Gish accepts the Queen's
Gambit not something you would expect
from a game where you only need a draw
uh but he obviously has something
prepared Knight F3 Knight to F6 and now
Pawn to E3 just going after the pawn
also called the the old way or the old
variation we have Pawn to E6 and Bishop
captures on C4 we have Pawn to A6 now
preparing B5 and C5 castles and pawn to
C5 we have D captures and C5 and Bishop
captures we have an early Queen trade
captures captures and now Bishop to E2
so all been play before nothing new here
uh King to E7 and now Knight B to D2 We
have Bishop to D7 the bishop can now
come to C6 or to B5 if needed and Rook
to D1 uh we have Rook to C8 uh and now
uh Pawn to B3 preparing to F and get to
the dark Square Bishop to this diagonal
so okay Bishop to B5 offering a trade of
Bishops and harik Krishna goes Knight to
C4 he refuses to to trade he says if you
want to trade then you have to give up
Bishop for Knight which will leave me
with the bishop pair and here we have
Knight KN beat to D7 uh getting us to to
a point where we reach new territory
there is a game between danil dubov and
Tim arum that reached this position
where Knight to C6 was played but here
we have Knight B to D7 and it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see uh how uh har
Krishna goes about this he plays Bishop
to B2 of course you want to get your
Bishop to this diagonal Knight to B6 now
preparing some trades here and Knight F
to E5 again saying if you want to trade
you're going to have to trade Bishop for
Knight Knight captures on C4 Knight
captures and Gish goes for it he plays
Bishop captures on C4 and with play on
both sides of the board this could be a
little bit risky as the bishop pair is
now incredibly powerful but uh like I
said Gish only needs a draw to uh almost
certainly qualify for the candidate
tournament and he is certain that he
will be able to fight Bishop uh Knight
versus Bishop so G6 removing this as a
permanent Target now you can uh move the
knight uh Bishop back to E2 now with the
pawn set light squares here the bishop
will come to this diagonal to put more
pressure on the queen side uh Knight
back to D7 and now Rook a to C1 we have
Bishop to D6 offering a trade of Rooks
uh and pawn to F4 so you don't have to
worry about this Pawn being a Target uh
we have Rook captures on C1 and Rook
captures on C1 Pawn to A5 uh grabbing
more space here also uh you want to if
you want to further Advance your pawns
you don't want the pawn on A6 to be a
Target and you also stop White's
expansion on the queen side so here
Bishop to B5 uh now putting pressure uh
on the Knight here Knight to B6 we have
Pawn to G3 and Rook to C8 offering
further trades which will leave us with
a uh Bishop pair versus bishop and
knight uh so Pawn to E4 Pawn to F6 and
now King to F2 and Gish finally trades
Rook captures and C1 Bishop captures and
Bishop to C5 with check King F3 and now
Knight to C8 and now the real question
is can Hari push this for a win somehow
the only one of course who can play for
a win is is white with the bishop pair
unless he really messes something up the
question is how do you do it if you
trade pawns on the queen side then it's
it's a dead draw of course you will not
be able to do do anything with your
Bishop pair if the plays on only one
side of the board that's sort of the the
big advantage of the bishop pair versus
a knight that the Bishops can control
the entire board right away so here he
starts with Pawn to E5 and Gish logs the
position in Pawn to F5 uh Bishop to E3
he offers a trade of Bishops as he
doesn't uh find a way on how to continue
because it's very hard all of the
squares are covered and there's no way
uh for the king to actually infiltrate
uh so Pawn to B6 by Gish offering a
trade on C5 and uh well everyone thought
that um har Krishna will try to to try
to find some way into Black's Camp there
really isn't any so he just trades here
Bishop captures and C5 5 b captures and
now he plays King to E3 hoping to get
his King here to capture the pawn uh but
Knight to B6 and he was in this position
un move 31 that Hari Krishna and gkes
agreed to draw as there is nothing more
to be done here all of the squares are
covered the pawns are doing a wonderful
job and with the Knight controlling A4
and C4 uh there's just no way for the
white king to break through the bishop
um has no business here the pawns are on
dark squares and these pawns that are on
light squares are nicely defended by the
king like I said if you if you try and
uh if you get your king let's say to C3
and then you play A3 and B4 you trade
all of the pawns on the queen side then
you're only left with the pawns on the
king side then it's even easier for the
Knight then it might even be Knight that
has the advantage at some point and if
you if you just maybe try and go your
you know your king this way uh then
black will just put a king here and I
mean you still have nothing so that draw
uh nicely done by GES he said that he he
got his two wins in the tournament and
then he just slowed down he just didn't
want to mess up any EV because he said
after the World Cup he really had a
couple of events that he was not happy
with uh so now he got his two wins and
he was able to cling onto first place
for the rest of the tournament now it's
still unclear as one of the games is
still happening that could overtake gkos
as the sole leader h doesn't matter he
will overtake Anish gear in the FI
circuit with uh uh with a sole lead or
even with a shared lead in this
tournament so uh if nothing while
happens in the world rapid and Blitz
Championship GES goes U onto the
candidates tournament uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it and a
little bit of extra info regarding the
candidates tournament uh I would like to
thank kenet F John dogale even Sterling
niola wi and Maximo ien for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
what's happening in the Chess World but
we are looking for that next alza game
as if he wins this one he overtakes
Wesley as the highest rated player who
could qualify for the candidates
tournament if fedi decides to rate the
these games uh so yeah and once again
hope you enjoyed it and yeah see you
soon